israel hat sich vorgenommen der
Terrorgruppe Hamas den Gar auszumachen
das Ziel dass sie mehrmals wiederholt
haben ist es sie auszulöschen koste es
was es wolle um dies zu erreichen hat
Israel nicht gezögert all seine
kampfkapazitäten zu Lande zu Wasser und
in der Luft zu mobilisieren
einschließlich der Einberufung von 360
000 Reservisten zum Zeitpunkt der
Aufnahme dieses Videos sind nach den
dreiwöchigen massiven Luftangriffen auf
die Stellungen der in Gaza und ersten
Einzelmissionen der Infanterie zur
Aufklärung und Erkundung der Situation
von Geiseln erstmals auch größere
Verbände israelischeer Bodentruppen in
den Norden des Gazastreifens
eingedrungen Ministerpräsident Benjamin
Netanyahu erklärte damit habe die zweite
Phase der Operation gegen die
Terrororganisation chamas
begonnen in erwegung gezogen wird ein
neuer landangriff auf den Gazastreifen
eine Art von Operation für die es leider
einige präzidenzfälle gibt in den 18
Jahren seit sich Israel aus dem
Gazastreifen zurückgezogen hat hat der
hebräische Staat bereits zwei
bodeninvasionen dort durchgeführt die
erste im Jahr 2009 war die Operation
klet bei der israelische Truppen 15 Tage
lang vor Ort waren die zweite fand 2014
statt und wurde als Operation protective
Edge bekannt im zweiten Fall dauerte die
Invasion 19 Tage in beiden Fällen gingen
den Operationen raketenabschüsse aus dem
Gazastreifen auf israelische Wohngebiete
voraus diese Operationen wurden stets
außerhalb der am dichtesten besiedelten
Gebiete durchgeführt mit anderen Worten
die israelischen Soldaten drangen nicht
in Gaza Stadt oder andere Städte ein
sondern operierten hauptsächlich in den
Gebieten die am nächsten an der Grenze
lagen allerdings deutet alles darauf hin
dass es diesmal anders sein wird die
israelischen Streitkräfte haben durch
ihre Sprecher bereits unmissverständlich
signalisiert dass die Offensive dieses
Mal weitaus größer ausfallen wird das
Ausmaß dieser Aktion wird noch größer
sein als alles bisher Gesehene und noch
härter es wird sehr unschön wir werden
sehr sehr aggressiv gegen die chamas
Vorgehen wir alle sollten einen
Paradigmenwechsel in erwegung ziehen
Richard Hecht Israels
Militärsprecher die Zeit in der man mit
diesen wilden verhandeln konnte ist
vorbei jetzt ist es an der Zeit die
terrorinfrastruktur der Hamas zu
zerstören sie vollständig zu beseitigen
damit solche grolltaten nie wieder
begangen werden zunächst einmal hat
Israel das roof kncking eingestellt bei
diesen wurde eine kleine sprengkladung
als evakuierungswarnung auf das Dach
eines Gebäudes geworfen bevor es richtig
Bombard wurde es scheint dass nach dem
Massaker der Hamas an israelischen
Zivilisten am 7 Oktober sowohl die
politischen Kräfte als auch die
israelische Öffentlichkeit selbst ihre
Sichtweise radikal verändert haben im
Moment sieht es also nicht so aus als ob
einer viel umfangreicheren Kampagne
etwas im Wege stehen würde angesichts
dieses Szenarios ist es jedoch wichtig
einige Punkte zu
beachten erstens ist der Gazastreifen
ein ziemlich dicht besiedeltes Gebiet
und eine militärische Kampagne dort wird
extrem viele Ressourcen und auch
Menschenleben eben Kosten und ja das
gilt für beide Seiten andererseits
dürfen wir jedoch nicht vergessen dass
die Bedrohungen die derzeit auf den
jüdischen Staat lauern nicht nur von der
Hamas kommen israel steht im Fadenkreuz
des Irans und alleer regionalen Gruppen
die von Teheran unterstützt werden
darüber haben wir bereits in unserem
letzten Video hier auf visualpitik
gesprochen und das erklärt dann
Nachrichten wie diese 15 Oktober 2023
die USA schicken ein zweiten
Flugzeugträger ins östliche Mittelmeer
die USS Eisenhauer wird sich der USS
Ford vor Israel schließen im heutigen
Video erklären wir euch im Detail woher
diese Gruppen kommen wo sie operieren
wer sie finanziert und welche Bedrohung
sie wirklich für Israel darstellen zuvor
muss ich jedoch eine Entdeckung mit euch
teilen vielleicht interessiert es euch
ja zu sehen wo ich eigentlich meine
videoskripte schreibe nun wenn es das
Wetter erlaubt setze ich mich meistens
im Garten an mein a4i Tablet und haue in
die Tasten vorher muss ich mich jedoch
ausgebig informieren aus dem Web aus
Studien und natürlich auch aus der
Presse und dabei bin ich auf eine App
gestoßen die sowohl auf meinem Handy als
auch Tablet und PC läuft und mein
Leseerlebnis geradezu revolutioniert hat
readedley readedley ist ein digitaler
Aboservice für Zeitschriften und
Zeitungen so etwas wie Spotify für
Printmedien es bietet eine Unmenge an
deutschsprachigen und internationalen
Lieblingstiteln die derzeit nur einen
Klick entfernt sind ohne dass ich zig
Abos bei verschiedenen Verlagen
abschließen muss readedley ermöglicht es
mir auf über 7000 Zeitschriften und
Millionen von Artikeln zuzugreifen und
das beste man kann sein Konto mit bis zu
fünf anderen Menschen teilen das macht
readedle zur perfekten Lösung für die
gesamte Familie der Hammer im Oktober
gibt es die ersten zwei Monate zum
Schnupperpreis von nur 1,99 € danach
beträgt der Preis 14,99 € man kann das
Abo aber jederzeit kündigen wichtig
dieses super Angebot kannst du nur über
den Link in der Videobeschreibung und
nur noch bis Ende Oktober nutzen also
lass es dir nicht entgehen so und jetzt
fragst du dich aber sicher welchen
Content dir readedle bietet nun ich habe
mich dies auch gefragt und war dann
komplett Buff von renommierten
Qualitätszeitung wie z.B der neuürcher
Zeitung eine der letzten Bastionen des
deutsch sprigen Liberalen Journalismus
dem Guardian dem independent der Welt
und unglaublich vielen anderen über
unzählige wissenschafts Ratgeber Finanz
und hobbymazine bis hin zu Comics das
rortiment wird auch ständig erweitert
kürzlich ist z.B das komplette Angebot
des burdavlags inklusive Focus Focus
Money und so weiter hinzugekommen mich
hat auch beeindruckt dass wirklich aus
allen Ecken des politischen Spektrums
was dabei ist ob links Mitte oder rechts
so kann man dann auch mal außerhalb der
eigenen Bubbel stübern was ja besonders
wertvoll für die Erweiterung des eigenen
meinungshorizonts ist in diesem riesigen
Repertoire findest garantiert auch du
sowohl deine lieblingsmedien als auch
jene die du hast aber genau diese
Mischung macht doch am meisten Spaß und
bereitet unendliches Lesevergnügen
natürlich gibt es eine offline
Lesefunktion mit der man seine
Lieblingsartikel auch überall unterwegs
genießen kann sogar wenn man gerade kein
Internet hat und überlegt mal digitales
Lesen von Magazinen und Zeitungen spart
Tonnen an CO2 und Müll Ridley hat
ausgerechnet dass es 16600 Tonn CO2
einspart was etwa den jährlichen Ausstoß
von 7000 PKB entspricht nicht schlecht
oder also tauche ein in die unendliche
Vielfallt der Magazine und Zeitungen bei
Ridley klick jetzt gleich auf den Link
in der Videobeschreibung um jetzt im
Oktober die ersten zwei Monate für nur
1,99 € auszuprobieren wie gesagt es ist
unverbindlich und jederzeit kündbar ich
bin überzeugt davon dass du dein neues
Leseerlebnis genießen wirst so und nun
begeben wir uns schnell in den
aufgewühlten Nahen Osten um die Akteure
des Terrors ausgiebig unter die Lupe zu
nehmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aufgepasst
[Musik]
ich glaube es gibt kaum Zweifel der Nahe
Osten ist eine der unruhigsten Regionen
der Welt und in dieser ganzen Region
stellt Israel das Epizentrum vieler
Konflikte und erbitterter Feindschaften
da weil seine Gegner entweder ganz
Israel für sich beansprochen oder die
Juden sogar vertreiben und das Land
komplett islamisieren
wollen was ihr hier in rot seht sind die
Länder oder Gebiete die unter der
Führung des islamischen Regimes der
ayatollas im Iran stehen und Israel
aktiv bekämpfen wie ihr sehen könnt ist
der hebräische Staat im Norden Süden und
Osten praktisch von feindlichen Gruppen
und Staaten umgeben im Süden im
Gazastreifen gibt es die chamas und den
sogenannten palästinensischen
islamischen dihad zwei mit dem Iran
Verbündete Gruppen die von der
iranischen Revolutionsgarde finanziert
ausgebildet und bewaffnet werden im
Norden im Libanon gibt es die hisesbala
deren militärischer Flügel hauptsächlich
im mehrheitlich schiitischen Teil des
Landes operiert die gesbala ist eine
äußerst mächtige Terrorgruppe die sich
in einem ständigen Krieg gegen Israel
befindet im Nordosten befindet sich das
alassad Regime in Syrien ein
historischer Verbündeter der ayatollas
der der Schlüssel dafür ist dass
iranische Waffen die hisesbalah
erreichen und Teheran den Norden Israels
bedrohen und notfalls angreifen kann und
schließlich gibt es im Irak schiitische
Milizen die ebenfalls unter direkter
Kontrolle des Irans stehen wie z.B die
badorganisation und katb hisisbalah
proiranische Gruppen die einen enormen
Fluss auf die irakische Politik
haben all diese Elemente oder zumindest
die meisten davon bilden eine
anti-israelische und antiwestliche Achse
die als Achse des Widerstands bekannt
ist innerhalb dieser Achse gibt es vor
allem zwei Akteure die mit ihrem
erklärten Ziel Israel zu vernichten
besonders gefährlich sind eine
wesentlich einflussreichere und
gefährlichere Gruppe für Israel als jede
arabische formation in Gaza oder der
Westbank einschließlich der Hamas denn
noch ist es im Moment die Hamas und ich
möchte Beton vor allem die hispala die
die größte Bedrohung für den hebräischen
Staat darstellt also wollt ihr wissen
warum und wozu sie imstande sind nun
genau das werden wir uns jetzt
ansehen die
gazafront die gazafront ist
hauptsächlich in zwei militärisch starke
Gruppen aufgeteilt Hamas und
palästinensischer islamischer dihad der
Hauptunterschied zwischen diesen beiden
Gruppen ist dass die kamamas neben ihrem
terroristischen Arm auch einen
politischen Arm hat der in diesem
Zusammenhang wie ihr wahrscheinlich alle
wisst den Gazastreifen regiert der
palästinensische islamische dihad
hingegen ist eine reine Terrorgruppe die
vor allem über ihre alkutzbrigaden
operiert aber wenn es darauf ankommt
sind beide Gruppen in ihrem Ziel einig
den hebäischen Staat zu bekämpfen und
auszulöschen seht es euch an 23 juni
2023 der iranische oberste Führer
hamenei empfängt die Terrorchefs von
Hamas und den Islamischen Jihad in teh
نفقات انا اقول لك انا اذا بدي احسب شو
دفعوا الايرانيين للفلسطينيين عبر 30 سنه
انا اقول لك مليارات الدولارات ممكن الناس
تستغرب احسبوا وشوفوا شو نفق مليارات
الدولارات وفي حين دول عربيه لا تدفع 100
دولار لما اقول 150 مليون دولار سنويا حما
اضربهم في 10 سنين قديش بطلع مليار ونص
دولار اضربهم في 20 سنه بيطلع 3 مليار
دولار
ja ziemlich beeindruckend und
erschrecken zugleich nicht
wahr aber nun da wir wissen wie dieas
finanziert wird wer sie mit Waffen
versorgt und wer ihre Kämpfer ausbildet
müssen wir uns noch ein paar Fragen
stellen wie stark ist die militärisch
eigentlich wozu sind sie imstande nun
wir können sagen dass dieas in den
letzten Jahren anspruchsvoller geworden
ist als S 1987 gegründet wurde war sie
nichts weiter als eine rudimentäre
unorganisierte radikale militante Gruppe
eine Splittergruppe der
Muslimbruderschaft seit dem hat sich
allerdings einiges verändert die chamas
die derzeit rund 30.000 reguläre Kämpfer
in ihrem bewaffneten Flügel hat verfügt
auch über Kampferfahrung die
israelischen Interventionen im
Gazastreifen in Jahren 2009 und 2014
haben der Gruppe viel Erfahrung gebracht
sie ist jetzt eine gut ausgerüstete
semiprofessionelle Armee ein gutes
Beispiel dafür sind ihre ballistischen
Raketen
um euch eine Vorstellung davon zu geben
die chamas hat mit Hilfe des Irans
gelernt das bekannte israelische
Raketenabwehrsystem aandom zu
überwiinden und hat sowohl die Anzahl
als auch die Reichweite ihrer Raketen
erhöht während die chamas im Jahr 2014
z.B maximal 4500 Raketen 50 Tagen
abfeuern konnte feuerte sie bei den
Zusammenstößen im Jahr 2021 inur
anderthalb Wochen 4300 Raketen ab mit
anderen Worten die Hamas hat ihre
ballistischen Fähigkeiten möglicherweise
um das Fünffache erhöht und ist
gleichzeitig mit Raketen ausgerüstet die
auch weit entfernte Städte wie telaviv
und Jerusalem erreichen
können außerdem und das ist wichtig hat
ichamas seit dem Krieg 2014 gelernt ihre
militärische Infrastruktur viel besser
zu verstecken Infrastruktur die heute
größtenteils unterirdisch ist in Bunkern
unter Krankenhäusern und Schulen es
überrascht nicht dass viele dieser
Tunnel größtenteils mit Baumaterialen
gebaut wurden die von der
internationalen Gemeinschaft ver wieder
Aufbau und Entwicklungsprojekte
gespendet wurden aber diese skandalöse
und systematische Förderung des Terrors
unter anderem durch die EU werde ich auf
meinem eigenen Kanal auseinandernehmen
ich werde ihn euch verlinken also schaut
vorbei falls ihr noch nicht kennt fakt
ist diese terrortunnel werden nicht nur
zum verstecken sondern auch für den
Import von geschmuggelten Waffen aus
Ägypten genutzt und als wäre das alles
noch nicht genug hat die Hamas bei den
schrecklichen Anschlägen vom 7 Oktober
2023 auch noch eine gewisse Raffinesse
an Intelligenz
bewiesen nach Berichten von
militäranalüsten kannte die Hamas sowohl
die Position der israelischen
Überwachungskameras als auch die der
bewegungszensoren die man entlang der
Grenze angebracht hatte viele der
terrorteams waren deswegen in der Lage
sie mit Waffen der elektronischen
Kriegsführung zu zerstören oder
auszuschalten außerdem nutzten sie
drohen und führten einen Teil des
Überfalls auf Israel auf Gleitschirmen
mit kleinen Motoren durch das große
Risiko dem sich die israelischen
Verteidigungskräfte im Kampf in den
Städten Gazas gegenü sehen besteht darin
dass die Hamas noch mehr solche
Überraschungen berei hält Überraschungen
die eine bodeninvasion in ein schwer zu
kontrollierendes Szenario verwandeln
könnten
daher ist es derzeit unklar wie weit
eine militärischer Einmarsch in den
Gazastreifen gehen könnte und wie weit
Israelis bereit wären einzudringen das
Risiko könnte verdammt hoch sein die
Wahrheit ist jedoch dass wenn es eine
Sache gibt die Israel mehr als alles
andere beunruhigt dann ist es die
hisbalah ganz genau die Hamas mag eine
viel aktivere Organisation sein wenn es
darum geht Angriffe gegen den
hebräischen Staat zu organisieren und
auszuführen aber wenn wir über die
hisbala sprechen reden wir über weit
überlegene Fähigkeiten also pas gut auf
was wir euch jetzt zeigen werden meine
Lieben visualpolitik Zuschauer das
worüber wir jetzt sprechen werden ist
eine verdammt ernste
[Musik]
Sache der gamechanger kommt weder aus
der westb noch aus
Gaza ganz genau die hisbalah ist
keinesfalls zu unterschätzen sie ist
eine lebanesische schiitische
muslimische politische Partei das heißt
sie gehört demselben Zweig des Islam an
der auch in Iran vorherrscht wedigerß
hat auch diese Gruppe ihren eigenen
bewaffneten Flügel die hisbalah wurde
offiziell 1985 während des libanesischen
Bürgerkriegs von 1985 bis 1990
gegründet sie hatte von Anfang an sehr
enge Verbindungen zum Iran Teheran sah
in dieser aufstrebenden schiitischen
Gruppe eine Möglichkeit seinen Einfluss
in der Region auszuweiten deshalb
zögerten sie nicht sie mit finanziellen
Mitteln zu versorgen in diesem
Zusammenhang heißt es dass sogar der
Name hispalavas Partei allahas bedeutet
von ayatollahinii selbst ausgewählt
wurde der politische Zweig ist im
Parlament vertreten undfügt über
beträchtliche nationale macht auch wenn
in den letzten Jahren die
Unzufriedenheit mit ihnen im Libanon
gewachsen ist und ihr politischer
Einfluss dadurch abgenommen hat das gilt
allerdings nicht für ihren militärischen
Flügel seit 1989 als das tifabkommen die
hisbalah zur einzig erlaubten
paramilitärischen Miliz im Libanon
machte hat ihr militärischer Flügel
enorm an Macht gewonnen und vor allem
verfügen sie über Männer eine Menge
Männer
nach Angaben ihres Anführers Hassan
nasrala hatte die hisbala im Jahr 2021
etwa 100.000 Kämpfer in ihren Reihen in
internationalen geheimdienstberichten
wird diese Zahl jedoch auf etwa 20.000
reguläre Soldaten und 20 bis 30 000
Reservisten reduziert in jedem Fall
handelt es sich um die größten
nichtstaatlichen Streitkräfte der Welt
das bedeutet dass die isbalah also
weitaus schlagkräftiger gilt als die
reguläre libanesische Armee außerdem hat
sie anders als ein Großteil der
israelischen Armee Erfahrung im
Bodenkampf die Israeli sind sehr gut bei
luftoperationen aber es ist nicht klar
ob sie bei bodenoperation genauso gut
sind zumindest sind sie nicht so
erfahren dagegen verfügt die hisbalah
über abertausende von Soldaten mit
bodenkampferfahrung die im syrienkrieg
an der Seite von Bashar Assads Truppen
gekämpft haben die Truppen der hisbalah
wissen was es heißt zu kämpfen und das
könnte ein gewaltiger Vorteil für Sie
sein aber natürlich macht es einen
riesen Unterschied ob man gegen
rebellenmizen oder eine professionelle
Armee kämpft aber warum sagen wir nun
dass die hisbala für Israel und
allgemein für die Entwicklung des
Konflikts wirklich entscheidend ist nun
im Grunde sagen wir das deswegen weil
wir hier von einer Armee sprechen die
mit der eines Landes durchaus
vergleichbar ist wir reden also nicht
von einer einfachen Terrorgruppe die mit
Jeeps und Pickers herumfährt die in
einer schäbigen Werkstatt umgebaut
wurden die hesballa verfügt über relativ
fortschrittliche Waffen die gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge und Artilleriegeschütze
hauptsächlich aus dem Iran und Russland
sowie über Raketen und zwar jede Menge
Raketen und andere bewaffnete Flugkörper
um euch eine Vorstellung zu geben laut
dem Center for strategic and
international studies verfügt die
hisbalah über etwa 130 000 Raketen und
Flugkörper und ja ihr habt richtig
gehört 130
[Musik]
000 ein großer Teil dieses Arsenals
besteht aus tragbaren ungelenkten
bodenboden artillerieraketen allerdings
verfügen sie auch über zahlreiche
Flugabwehr und schiffsabwehrraketen
sowie über mittelstreckenlenkraketen die
bestimmte Ziele tief im israelischen
Staatsgebiet treffen können das ist also
viel viel mehr als die Hamas zur
Verfügung hat und deshalb denken viele
dass der Schaden beträchtlich sein
könnte wenn die hispalach sich
entscheiden wde würde in einen
bewaffneten Konflikt gegen Israel
einzutreten ja Israel ist immer noch
stärker aber der Schaden könnte
beträchtlich
werden und deswegen ist es die hesballa
nicht die Hamas die nicht nur in Israel
sondern auch in Ländern wie den USA und
Großbritannien für große Beunruhigung
sorgt und wie wir bereits gesagt haben
erklärt dies Nachrichten wie diese USA
stationieren 12000 Marinesoldaten mit
zweiten Flugzeugträger vor Israel zehn
amerikanische Schiffe aus zwei
Kampfgruppen sollen einen größeren
Konflikt verhindern
Großbritannien schickt Schiffe und
Flugzeuge zur Unterstützung Israels im
Mittelmeer wenn die hisbala in großem
Umfang in den Konflikt Eintritt und ihre
ballistischen Kräfte gegen Israel
einsetzt ist es sehr wahrscheinlich dass
der hebräische Staat Luftunterstützung
und vielleicht auch Unterstützung von
der seeer benötigt um dann eine solche
Offensive zu stoppen und den Schaden zu
begrenzen Unterstützung die die USA und
Großbritannien anscheinend vorerst
anbieten
wollen und ja wir sagen in großem Stil
denn die hisbalah hat bereits kleinere
Anschläge von von geringerer Größe
verübt die aber eine klare Botschaft
vermitteln wir sind hier wir beobachten
alles was ihr tut und wenn wir der
Meinung sind dass ihr die Grenzen
überschreitet werden unsere Raketen zu
einem Feuerregen gegen euch hisballah
schießt auf idfposten und feuert Raketen
auf Panzer bei neuen Zusammenstößen an
der libanesischen Grenze aber das ist
noch nicht alles die hisbalah ist nicht
nur extrem gefährlich für Israel die
Bedrohung geht weit darüber hinaus denn
im Gegensatz zu Hamas ist die hisbalah
eine Gruppe die international operiert
in diesem Zusammenhang ist sie für
zahlreiche Terroranschläge gegen Juden
im Ausland verantwortlich mit anderen
Worten für die hisbalah richtet sich der
Krieg nicht nur gegen die Existenz des
Staates Israel sondern auch gegen das
gesamte jüdische Volk wollt ihr ein paar
Beispiele kein Problem ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher dass euch einige davon
bekannt vorkommen werden sowohl
libanesische Amtsträger als auch
westliche Geheimdienste beschuldigen die
hisballa und ihre Unterorganisationen
Entführungen und Selbstmordattentate zu
[Applaus]
verüben z.B verübte die hisballah 1983
ein selbstmordattemptat dass das
hoptquartier der US-Marine in Beirut
zerstörte dabei wurden 241
Militärangehörige getötet außerdem
verübten Sie einen weiteren Anschlag auf
eine französische kasserne bei dem 58
fallschirmjäer getötet wurden und im
selben Jahr einen weiteren
Selbstmordanschlag auf die US-Botschaft
bei dem 63 Menschen starben 1992 griff
die hisbala die israelische Botschaft in
Argentinien an und tötete 22 Menschen
und verletzte mehr als 240 1994 wurden
ebenfalls in Argentinien Autobomben beim
jüdischen Zentrum Amia in Buenos Aires
gelegt dabei wurden 85 Menschen getötet
und mehr als 300
verletzt erst kzlich sprengte die
hisbala ein Bus voller israelischer
Touristen in burlgar Bulgarien in die
Luft und tötete sechs Menschen und
verletzte 32 Bulgarien sieht klare
Anzeichen dafür dass die hesbalah hinter
dem Bombenanschlag in Burgas steckt wie
ihr seht handelt es sich um eine
internationale Terrorgruppe die viel
stärker und aggressiver agiert als die
kamamas oder der palästinensische
islamische dihad sie ist besser
finanziert und verfügt über eine solide
Organisation die auch im Ausland aktive
Zellen hat nach Angaben verschiedener
Thinktanks die sich auf den Nahen Osten
spezialisiert haben stellt der Iran der
hballah je nach Jahr zwischen 100 und
800 Millionen US-Dollar zur
[Musik]
Verfügung aus all diesen Gründen könnte
der Eintritt der hisbala in den Konflikt
eine radikale Veränderung der Situation
bedeuten durch den Eintritt von mehr
Akteuren viel mehr Druck auf die
israelischen Verteidigungskräfte und
benötigt sogar eine mögliche Eskalation
mit dem Iran ich möchte an dieser Stelle
betonen dass Israel höchstwahrscheinlich
der stärk bleiben wird aber das Problem
ist dass wir bereits über einen ganz
anderen Konflikt sprechen würden von
einer begrenzten Operation zur
Liquidierung der Hamas würden wir zu
einem echten Krück übergehen der viele
der Errungenschaften die die israelische
Gesellschaft in letzten Jahren erreicht
hat gefährden könnte wir sprechen von
vielen Opfern der lehung eines großen
Teils der Wirtschaftstätigkeit und einem
großen materiellen Schaden und das ist
eine große Bedrohung für den Staat
Israel wir werden die Lage natürlich
weiterhin analysieren um euch auf dem
laufenden zu halten also vergesst bitte
nicht alle unsere Kanäle zu abonnieren
und auch das Glöckchen zu aktivieren und
bis dahin seid ihr erstmal mit eurer
Meinung an der Reihe denkt ihr dass die
Hamas diesen Krieg überleben wird glaubt
ihr dass die hisbala am Ende mit einem
großangelegten Angriff auf Israel in den
Konflikt einsteigen wird und wie wird
eurer Meinung nach dieser Konflikt enden
wie immer wenn ich auf eure Beiträge im
Kommentarbereich schon hochgradig
gespannt ich hoffe dass ihr bei diesem
Video etwas gelernt habt falls ja geht
ih ein Like Teil mit euren Freunden und
diskutiert es auch mit ihnen vergesst
bitte auch nicht uns eine kleine
freiwillige Spende zukommen lassen damit
wir dieses Projekt weiterführen können
den Spendenlink findet ihr in der
Videobeschreibung macht gut und bis zum
nächsten
[Musik]
Mal